[Music]
every map and mode released as DLC for
titanfall 2 is free and developer
Respawn Entertainment has detailed
what's coming next I'm Matt and this
gamespot news update is prepared for
titanfall the previously announced life
our multiplayer mode arrives in February
and pits two teams of six against each
other in rounds at only last minute to
win each round you'll have to eliminate
the other team or hold on to the single
neutral flag when the clock ticks down
to zero Livefyre takes place on unique
maps created specifically for the mode
and designer Griffin Dean says that they
were made to push players together and
force them into combat in March players
will get an update that adds new prime
Titans and cosmetics to the in-game
store it also brings a large patch that
as usual balance adjustments and bug
fixes in addition to a new weapon pilot
execution and the return of titanfall
one map colony no specific dates have
been revealed for the free titanfall 2
content but we'll keep you updated as
for their information is revealed so for
that and more from the world of video
games stay tuned to gamespot